today let's discuss the number one sign
of iodine overload the symptoms from not
having enough iodine are just as bad as
getting too much iodine iodine is a
trace mineral meaning that it's needed
in very small tiny amounts so we're
talking about
micrograms not milligrams so the amount
of iodine you need on a regular basis
should be between
150 to 200 micrograms per day but you
don't need a lot there is an iodine
supplement called potassium iodide which
is meant to take as a protection against
some type of nuclear radiation exposure
and potassium iodide should not be taken
on a regular basis as your iodine
supplement now I will say that it's more
common not to get enough iodine a lot of
people are deficient than to get too
much iodine but you should be aware of
certain things that can happen if you
take too much now since we are on the
topic of iodine we should probably talk
a little bit about Hashimoto's okay that
is an autoimmune condition it's a
hypothyroid condition it was discovered
by a doctor out of Japan thus his last
name Hashimoto's which is a Japanese
name and by the way as a side note Japan
has more Hashimoto's disease than any
other place in the world and I think
because of this one point Hashimoto's is
really not caused by an iodine
deficiency but can be aggravated or even
triggered with taking too much iodine
and in Japan they do consume a
tremendous amount of iodine from seaweed
sea kelp seafood
Etc but I do want to point out if you're
taking like 150 to 200 micrograms of
iodine you're usually not going to
trigger Hashimoto's it's when you take a
lot of iodine that you could potentially
trigger it now if there's something that
triggers Hashimoto's what can happened
is the thyroid can start producing a lot
of hydrogen peroxide and then hydrogen
peroxide is a very very irritating and
corrosive to the thyroid gland but
normally our bodies have enough
neutralizing factors to buffer that
hydrogen peroxide and one being selenium
which by the way selenium is really good
for Hashimoto's it's also necessary to
convert T4 to T3 which is the active
form of the thyroid hormone but the
selenium is also like a precursor to
glutathione which is the liver's
antioxidant so probably what's happening
with Hashimoto's is we have a situation
where we don't have enough selenium or
glutathione or we have a weak liver or
even we have some problem in the gut
that's where your your immune barrier is
and if there's some type of leaky gut
situation or increase permeability in
the gut because there's inflammation
that's usually where Hashimoto's starts
and this is why there's such a huge
association between things like gluten
and Hashimoto's but what you need to
know is that Hashimoto's is not an
iodine deficiency and too much can
actually trigger Hashimoto's situation
there's also some other factors that I
just want to just briefly touch on with
the Advent of DNA testing you can now
get your DNA tested and find out where
your weaknesses are and if there's some
type of mutation in your genes it's
called a polymorphism you can also have
a weakness or a higher risk factor of
getting an autoimmune disease especially
to your thyroid and that's called
Hashimoto's so for example if you have
this gut issue you're consuming a lot of
gluten and you're low in selenium you
could be much greater at risk for
getting Hashimoto's than someone else
but I think also hypothyroidism could be
a protective mechanism some type of
compensation from having too much iodine
that's just one theory that I have just
because too much iodine could be very
damaging to the body all right now let's
dive into the number one symptom that
someone would have relating to getting
too much iodine okay the number one
symptom is a highly irritable energy
that keeps you from sleeping okay so
let's say for example you're just you're
in this flight of flight mode and you
just your body is just on edge and you
just can't sleep that is usually one of
the first signs that of an iodine excess
now you could also have that symptom
from other things like low B1 for
example and being stressed because your
adrenals in overdrive but just realize
that too much iodine can activate the
thyroid which can then activate too much
sympathetic nervous system too much
flutter fight and so that's really one
of the first signs that occurs with
taking too much iodine here's some other
ones fast pulse rate okay like your
pulse rate is just boom boom boom but
again that can also come from other
things like low potassium or low vitamin
B1 another symptom of excess iodine
could be atrophib or heart arrhythmias
in general another one could be heat
intolerance or diarrhea or hand tremors
or your temperature is increasing but
you don't necessarily have a like an
infection fever it's just your body is
just hotter or you could even have bone
loss or osteopenia which is a
pre-oscoporosis situation
or another one would be a loss of
menstrual cycle or excessive sweating or
even and this is rare but you can have
what's called a thyroid storm all of
these symptoms could potentially be you
have too much iodine all right so what
is someone going to do if they have
symptoms of too much iodine well the
most important thing is to find out
where it's coming from and start to
eliminate iodine from your diet or your
supplements okay so let me just kind of
go through a list of sources of iodine
now there's a couple things I want to
mention related to getting too much
iodine first of all maybe you're taking
way too much seek help or seaweed in
your diet or you're consuming a lot of
iodized salts or a tremendous amount of
seafood or it could be a combination of
several supplements you're taking with
too much iodine so you want to read the
back of the label and just start
counting up how much iodine you really
getting and if it's over like 300
micrograms you should start cutting back
all right and the other question is
um is there a blood test or some test to
know if we have too much iodine okay
well there's a couple things in past
videos I talked about a skin test where
you can drop a little bit of iodine on
your skin put a little patch on and then
see if it gets absorbed or not over a
period of time and that's one test but
the problem with that test is it it
really only tells you
um recently what's going on in your body
there's a a much more accurate test to
do and that test is a urine test and if
I'm not mistaken it can even be a home
test okay and I'll put a link down below
to see if you can just get this test
ordered and you can send it right to
your house but the test is a urinary
collection test where you send your
urine off to the lab and they're
measuring something called urinary
iodine to creatinine ratio and when you
get that test done you want it below a
hundred
micrograms per gram okay
if it's above a hundred micrograms per
gram that means there's some source of
iodine that you're taking unknowingly
that's keeping your iodine a bit too
high all right so that's that now if you
have Hashimoto's okay I have a lot of
videos on this but
I wouldn't recommend taking extra iodine
instead I would take selenium okay now
preferably you get it from your food and
the food that has the highest selenium
is Brazil nuts maybe you just take a
couple of those per day that will be
enough or you just get a supplement and
only take what's on the back of the
label so it'll take a lot of synonym
because selenium is also a trace mineral
so you just need sufficient amounts so
if you have Hashimoto's there's a couple
really key points here there's a lot
more to know about it but I would
definitely take selenium okay I would
also take vitamin D very important
vitamin D has been shown to decrease the
antibodies in Hashimoto's okay and I
would recommend taking 20 to 30 000 IUS
per day
and lastly I would take a good natural
source of B1 because B1 can also help if
you notice a lot of these symptoms also
cross over to almost mimicking a B1
deficiency and so these symptoms can be
improved with B12 especially if you have
this sympathetic nervous system
dominance now also another hidden source
which is probably not your situation is
consuming a lot of Bakery Goods okay or
breads or pastas things like that
because a lot of times they use iodide
as one of the dough conditioners which
have something called iodate which is a
form of iodine and another thing I want
to bring up when you take um like
purified bile salts okay which is in my
gallbladder formula and where it's in a
lot of other products you're taking this
bile or even a form of tadka if you have
hyperthyroid symptoms just realize that
can make things a little bit worse
because that increases the conversion
through the liver from T4 to T3 so that
could be a really minor point but it can
just contribute to this problem if you
have too much iodine however if you need
more iodine that would be a great thing
to take because like I said before it's
more common to have a deficiency of
iodine than it is to have too much
iodine and also if you have Hashimoto's
I'm not saying that to completely you
know have zero amounts of iodine your
diet but just realize that you never
want to correct these things necessarily
with just a single
element like a mineral realize that in
nature it always comes in complexes so
if you are deficient for example in
iodine taking CCAP would be better than
just taking a single iodine because in
nature it never comes that way and if
you do use a single mineral to correct
something work with either your doctor
or a health care practitioner to help
get the levels just right because it's a
bit complex and also realize that 80
percent of the conversion from T4 to T3
the active form of the thyroid hormone
occurs through the liver and the kidney
so if you have a thyroid problem and
it's not Hashimoto's for example I mean
the problem could be in your liver or it
could be in your kidney that's creating
this problem so it's not always just a
thyroid issue now there's a really good
book that I recommend if you have a
thyroid problem or you want to get a lot
more information about the thyroid gland
itself it's by the author Isabella Wentz
and she's written several books about
the thyroid the one I would recommend
would be Hashimoto's protocol now since
we're on the topic of iodine and thyroid
I think it's very important to
understand other factors that can affect
the thyroid especially in the conversion
factors from t E4 to T3 and for that
information I put this video up right
here check it out